INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So in last week's video or
the last video, so probably
the same week, but
in the last video,
we talked about using
databases in the cloud.
So we're pivoting now to this
new domain of not working
on websites for the second.
We're just focusing on
developing and deploying
databases to be leveraged either
by our company, or our software
developers, or our web
developers, data scientists,
or maybe we just need again
a place to host our data.
Specifically, we're
going to be talking
about structured
data, so data that
has rows and columns, though
arguably similar steps can
be taken if we have
unstructured data as well too.
But for now, we're going to
focus on relational databases.
And to that end, I want to talk
today about Amazon's RDS, so
Relational Database Service.
So this is a tool, and that's
what you can see behind me.
So I guess I could
just drop myself out
of the way for a second.
Here we'll go down
the bottom right side.
How about that?
So this is a tool, zoom in a
bit, that is a managed service.
So it is managed in the sense
that if we deploy an RDS
instance, a database
instance, we
won't be expected to manage the
hardware or the infrastructure
in the back end.
Auto scaling should
happen automatically.
Security and all that stuff
should happen automatically.
We're purely defining what we
want our database to look like.
So today, in this
video, we're going
to all create a database
together basically, but be very
mindful that these do cost us.
This is actually kind of, by
construction, can't be smaller
than 20 gigabyte
database instances.
So we will be paying
for that storage.
So once you complete
this video, make
sure you delete your
database instance.
We'll get to an
assignment later on.
We'll have you create
one, leverage it,
and we'll talk about those
details when that time comes.
But for this assignment,
or better statement,
for this video, feel free
to work alongside me.
Deploy one, set it up.
But once you're
done, make sure you
follow the steps at the very
end to delete everything
as well too.
If not, I'm just going to go
through it and wipe things,
but I can't be on top of
this every day, all day.
So just please keep that in mind
and be considerate with that.
All right.
So with that out the way,
let's start by first,
if you haven't gotten
to this page yet,
you can just search RDS.
Click here, and it'll bring
you back to right where
we're at right now.
So now my internet's going to
be laggy and kind of hang here
for a second.
So there we go.
We're back to this now.
So what I want you to do is just
click Create Database first.
And so you can either
click it there,
or if that prompt
isn't showing up,
I don't know why my
internet is so slow today.
If that prompt is
not showing up,
you can click into
Database Instances.
And from here, you can
do Create Database.
Now under here,
we're going to do
Standard Create to start with.
And then you're
going to click MySQL.
So you see we have
Amazon Aurora, which is,
and they have details
on the right here.
Amazon Aurora MySQL
and PostgreSQL
compatible, starting at
about less than $1 a day.
But much faster than MySQL
and PostgreSQL, a little bit
more capacity, a bunch of
stuff, a bunch of features
associated with it.
Again, it's an
Amazon-specific product,
so you can imagine
it's going to be
integrated very well with
the rest of their services.
We're going to focus on MySQL.
It's a free, small,
lightweight database engine.
And so we'll start here.
It's pretty scalable actually.
We can leverage this
up to database sizes,
up to 64 terrabytes.
So it's going to be enough
for what we need to do.
There's also Oracle, Microsoft
SQL, Maria, PostgresSQL.
For example, things
like Microsoft SQL
will usually require
an extra upfront cost
for the licensing
of the software.
So for now, because we want
to keep things free and also
the most compatible on
different platforms,
we'll stick with MySQL.
And you can leave all that
the same, but versions here.
Technically, I'm not
going to change anything.
But if you do change
this, note that, again, I
can't guarantee always that
things work between versions.
Obviously, we're going
to try to run everything
we can on the free tier.
But note, that isn't
for everything,
or that doesn't guarantee
that it will be free.
It just says that this is
running at the free tier level,
right?
So it'll limit the
instances we're using.
But I think you only
have up to 750 hours
total on the free
tier, and that's again
when you're still in
that free tier window,
so after the first
year of the account.
So I'd be surprised
if any of these
will be free for our
account, but it's OK.
We'll still run it at the
free tier level in case
you're doing this on your
personal AWS account too.
So now we actually get
to go ahead and define
what our database instance
is going to look like.
So first off, the Database
Instance Identifier
is exactly what it sounds like.
The identifier for
your database instance.
So let's just call
this RDS MySQL demo.
Call it something unique.
It needs to be unique across
all database instances owned
by your AWS account
in the current region.
So if you do RDS MySQL
demo and mine's still live
or somebody else creates
that same exact name,
then it's going
to throw an error.
So just be mindful of that.
If you get an error here, the
name doesn't exist, that's why.
Under username, we can
just leave it as admin.
And then under password you can
either auto-generate a password.
Or since we're just playing
around with this for now,
I'm just going to start by
creating a password for this.
So you can call it
again whatever you want.
Just make sure you remember it.
So let me make this one.
Already messed up.
It's very hard to type
and talk at the same time.
There we go.
Under Instance
Configuration now, this
is again going to tell you
what kind of instances,
EC2 instances effectively do you
want running on the back end.
So you see, we have a
bunch of different options
here, though a lot
of them are going
to be grayed out because
we clicked the free tier.
So we're just going
to go to T2 micro
because we don't
need anything fancy.
We're going to stick with the
smallest one possible here.
So T2 micro should be
sufficient for our quick demo.
But again, if you decide to do
something for your final project
or anything that you
want more capacity for,
then scale appropriately, right?
You can see it provides
details on the number of vCPUs,
the amount of RAM, and even
also potentially network
throughput, right?
So the speed.
So you see you're getting
2-gig network speeds here.
So this is an actual issue.
If you know you need to
maximize these read/write speeds
across the network, then
make sure you do that.
So yeah.
And you can see you
can get all the way up
to an 8 vCPUs, 32 gigs of RAM.
So we'll take those.
And so now, we're
on to storage type.
We're going to just stick
with General Purpose, gp2.
But the important
thing to note here
is it's going to default to 200.
Do not do 200.
That's way too much
capacity, and we're
going to get charged
extra for it.
And we can again look at
the cost of gp2 pricing.
High performance block storage.
So gp2 is currently going for
$0.10 per gigabyte a month.
So again, let's just do
this math now really quick.
I got my phone out,
just do some quick back
of the envelope calculations.
You know I love that.
If we leave it at 200,
that would be obviously $20
per month per user.
And so now let's divide
that across the 30 days.
Let's say you accidentally leave
this live for the whole day.
So it costs about $0.67 per
user per day keeping this live.
But then multiply that by the
50 students taking this course,
and we're already
doing over $30 a day.
So do not leave
it at 200 in case
it's accidentally left live, and
I don't shut it down in time.
Step that down to 20.
That's the minimum
size you'll see here.
So just step it down to 20.
And then we'll still
delete it at the end,
but that's what
we'll do for now.
Notice too that they have
a really cool feature that
can be very useful, and
you can always click
these infos for the side here.
But it does exactly
what it says.
If I'm starting to reach
that gigabytes capacity,
I might not want it to have
just like not log my data.
Let's say I'm doing this
for storing the transactions
of my company, right?
The sales of our online
on our online platform.
Well, if all of a
sudden, our sales
are passing or surpassing
gigabytes in storage,
that's a good problem to have.
And let's not just miss out on
this data by hitting capacity.
Let's auto scale this up and
allow ourselves to still collect
that data because
that might arguably
be more valuable than the
cost associated with it.
But I don't want to pay
for stuff I don't need now.
So you see here how it defaults
to having a terabyte basically
of auto scaling max capacity.
Sorry.
Brain freeze there for a second.
So yeah.
Terabyte maximum is what
it's setting to you.
So that would basically
say like, OK, maybe we've
exceeded this 20 gigabytes.
Well, I'm going to let it scale
up or auto scale up to 1,000
gigabytes or a terabyte.
I'm going to do this off for
now because I don't need it.
But conceivably,
if you had it on,
you see you could set
up to basically up
to six terabytes for this.
So turn that off though for now.
Then over here, we are
going on to the choice now
of connectivity.
So if you have an existing EC2
compute resource that you want
to attach this to, you could.
We don't have
that, so we're just
going to leave that to Don't
connect to an EC2 compute
resource.
The VPC, we can just
leave this as the default.
No need to create
a new one here.
It's perfectly fine as it is.
And similarly, for
the subnet, you
don't need to change
the subnet either,
and it probably won't
have any other options.
What we do want to do
is enable public access
because I want to be able to
query this from my computer,
like my physical device, this
laptop that I'm working on
right now.
I want to be able to
query this database,
obviously with a
password and all that,
but I want to be able to
reach from the public.
Now that's not necessarily
going to always be the case.
And arguably, if
you're at a company,
it's probably going to be less
often that you would do this.
You might leave this as no.
And then there won't be a
public IP address assigned.
You'll have to be inside
the VPC to connect to this.
So an EC2 instance that's within
this VPC could query this,
but you wouldn't
be able to query it
from your local machine.
So if that extra
layer of security
is needed for your data, which
you'll know if that's the case,
then set that to no.
But for now, I do want to
have this just for simplicity,
so we'll leave that as yes.
Then for VPC security group,
I'm going to go ahead,
and I think I created one.
Yeah, this IS3600RDS
security group.
If that's available for you,
go ahead and click that.
You will likely need to be in
this Oregon region for that.
If it's not available, feel
free to create a new one.
But if you're going
to create a new one,
if you're in a different
region for whatever reason,
that's perfectly fine.
Just go ahead and name it.
What I just call
it, so is3600RDSsg.
And that way, for the
next user that comes on,
they'll have it available.
So feel free to help your fellow
teammate out if that's the case.
But you would do that.
And then you wouldn't need to do
a preference on the availability
zone.
And you can also just leave this
database port exactly the same.
So again, if you
need to create it,
if this one doesn't already
exist, go ahead and create it.
Leave all this.
Everything else is default.
If you are in this same one
and you can see
this security group,
then go ahead and select
it, if it lets me.
I don't know why all of
a sudden can't select it.
There we go.
So there we go.
Is3600 security group.
Now coming down here, this
database authentication
is again exactly what it says.
So if I want to
access this database,
is it sufficient to just do it
with a password authentication?
And that's what we're
going to do right now.
We assign a password.
We're going to log
in via that password.
So everything's OK there.
Do you want maybe more
security and insist
that they have to have IAM
database authentication, right?
Especially if they're doing
something from the command line,
this might be the
way you rather do it.
And then there's
also this extra step
here if you're using Kerberos
authentication, which
is I'm actually not familiar
with Kerberos authentication.
So let's look it up real quick.
My guess is some sort of
active directory symmetric key
cryptography.
OK.
So just another symmetric
key cryptography option.
And so you'll likely
have a directory
with the relevant information
there if you're using it.
But again, obviously
we're not going to use it
since I don't know what it is.
So we can just go and
leave it with that, The.
Password authentication for now.
We don't need to enable
enhanced monitoring.
We're not trying to watch
any metrics right now
or watch the process threads,
CPU usage, all that good stuff.
You again will know if
that's the right thing,
you need to be doing.
But for now, we're
perfectly fine without it.
Under Additional
Configuration, this
is going to be for, let
me make sure I scroll down
and follow along with my notes.
I'm not just going
off the rails here.
So under Additional
Configuration,
this is going to be just again,
what your initial database
name is going to be.
And so maybe I want
to call this demodb.
You can call it
whatever you want.
If you don't specify a database
name, RDS doesn't create one,
and then you just
have to create one
once you log in
to your database.
But we'll just set a
default one for now.
Leave the parameter group the
same, the option group the same.
We have the choice
now also of enabling
automated backups or not.
I'm going to leave
this on, and then we'll
see how we remove this
once we go to delete this,
just for the educational sake.
But this does again
exactly what it says.
This stuff is very clear
in what it's doing.
If we don't have this
enabled, then there
won't be any sort of
automated backups happening,
and you will be
kind of in charge
of making sure that everything
gets backed up as necessary.
If we do set it on, then we
click Enable Automated Backups.
We can specify the retention,
so basically how many days
do we keep backups for?
And so let's say we just
keep it for one day, right?
Maybe we know that if
our database goes down,
we'll be aware of
it within a day.
And so we can then roll back.
Or if we have an issue, we'll
be aware of it within a day,
so we'll only keep
up to one day.
That way, we don't have
too much stuff stored.
And then similarly, you
could have a backup window.
You can set that
yourself of when
you would like
that backup window
to be start time, the
duration, all that good stuff.
We'll just leave no
preference for now.
Then I'm also going to unclick
Copy Tags to Snapshots just
to reduce the things
we're accidentally saving.
Log Exports.
If you need to export
the CloudWatch logs,
very much go ahead and do that.
So our enabling auto
minor version upgrade.
So as long as it's
not a major like
if we're going from
MySQL 8.0 to 9.0,
that would be a major upgrade.
But maybe if there's
just an 8.0.39 to 8.0.41,
that's a minor upgrade.
That shouldn't break any sort
of backwards compatibility.
So maybe you want it to do that.
Maybe it's just adding
some extra security
or covering up some security
vulnerabilities or something
like that.
That isn't a major change.
And so you're not worried that
it's going to break something,
but you also want to
ensure that you have it.
If that's the case, then
go ahead and select this.
We'll just turn it off for now.
Maintenance Window
period, you want
pending modification or
maintenance apply to this.
So again, if you're like, hey, I
want these minor upgrades and/or
any sort of other maintenance
tasks done at a specific time,
maybe 3:00 AM every morning
because you know that
nobody's going to be logged on
or connecting to your database
then, that's how you set it up.
Deletion Protection
is actually the same
as we had with EC2 instances.
So if this option is enabled,
you can't delete the database.
Basically, you'll need to, if
you want to delete the database,
come back into this,
unselect it, and then delete
the database.
I'm going to leave this
unselected now, right?
Otherwise, you're
going to get an error
when you try to delete it.
So let's leave it unselected.
Don't click it.
And then finally, if we
had an associated estimate
for the cost, it
would show up here.
But we don't since we're
running this on the free tier.
So we can just
leave this for now.
So once that's done, you can go
ahead and click Create Database.
And then it should start
spinning it up now.
And so you'll see it right here.
This is my instance.
It's in this creating state.
If I click on it, it still
shows up as creating.
So I'll pause for
now, and then I'll
come back once mine is live.
And then you can also
hit play once it's live.
I realized before it
finishes getting created,
because mine's still in
the backing up status,
but I figured I might as well
show you this step as well too.
We also need to download
a SQL client, right?
So as it stands right now, we're
creating a database instance.
And this instance will exist on
some computers somewhere, right?
But I need to have
some way to query it.
So if you're very well
versed in Python already
and you know R or
something like that,
and you're planning
to just query it
from an application like your
Flask app, then by all means,
you could very much just
set up a database connection
and make that query happen.
What I'm going to
show you now actually
though is maybe a
different way to do this,
or better statement, probably an
easier way to do this, is let's
just say we want to
query it on our computer
and just be able to
manipulate it, whatever.
And so if you've
done SQL before,
you might have Microsoft SQL
Server already on your computer.
Or if you already have
the MySQL Workbench,
then you have the SQL
client we're going to use.
So if you don't, there's a link
in the notes for this lecture,
or you can open up or
visit this link here,
dev.mysql.com/download/workbench
and then choose your relevant
operating system.
So like for example,
I'd be on a Mac.
Or if you're on
Windows, select Windows.
So it'll be up to you, and
this is a step where, again, I
trust that you guys have the
skills to do this necessary.
But it'll be up to you
to make sure you download
the right version of this.
So choose the
correct architecture
or choose the correct version
for your operating system.
I already have it downloaded,
so it's not going to run for me.
But if you click Download
then on your relevant system,
it'll prompt you to
probably log in, sign up,
or begin your download
or log in or sign up
to begin the download.
You can also just
click No Thanks
and just start the download
for a quick download.
So it'll be a little bit of
a blue bar underneath it,
but that's OK.
Actually, let me see
if I can show it here.
Yeah.
So if you just click
Download, you'll
see it shows up, No thanks.
Just start my download.
That's what you'll click unless
you want to log in or sign up
for an Oracle account.
But now let me just make sure,
let's see if mine's there yet.
Otherwise, I can keep
continuing down the steps,
but I want to check.
But either way, our
next step is going
to be to connect
to the SQL client.
So, OK, mines available.
So you should be
showing available now
to if you are up
to speed with me.
If not, just pause it and wait
till that showing is available.
But once you have
that, then go ahead
and launch your MySQL client.
So I'm going to open
mine up here and then
drag it to the top monitor
once it actually goes live.
Here we go.
So now what you want to do is go
into your file or your toolbar
if you're on Windows.
It'll show up in the box down
here, wherever it shows up.
Go into here.
And then you're going to
click Connect to Database.
You can also hit Command U if
you're on a Mac or Control U
if you're on a Windows machine.
So we're going to do
Connect to Database.
And then we need to find the
host name for our instance.
And that is actually
just this endpoint
that's showing up on our screen
here on our database instance.
So you're going to
copy this endpoint.
So I did Control
C. And then where
it says host name,
Control V or Command V,
whatever machine you're on.
Under username, you're going
to set the username you set.
So if you followed along with
me, it should just be admin.
And then for password, click
store and keychain, or it
might say store and vault
if you're on a Windows.
It just depends on what
your instance, shows here
or your operating system
for what it shows here.
And then here you're going
to type in the password
that you came up with before
or that auto-generated password
that you had.
Click OK.
Everything's OK.
Then we should be good
here once we click OK.
So it's opening this up, so
that might take a second.
So just hang tight
while that launches.
And I guess I can
just pause for now,
and then we'll come
back in a second.
All right.
So once you've
finished that step,
you should see a window here
with your SQL Workbench.
Might be a different
color depending on what
your theme is on your computer.
But let me see if I can increase
the size of this at all.
Didn't realize how small
it was going to appear.
Let's see.
Tools, Configuration, Utilities.
You just have to
deal with it for now.
Yeah.
Let's do it preferences.
Let's see if we can get it here.
Fonts, 13.
Let's see if I can crease this
all to a little bit larger.
Anything else that I
can do to increase it.
OK.
Let's just see if this--
Gave me a little bit more
but not that big a deal.
So either way, you should
have this query window
now once you're connected.
And if not, walk back
those steps, make sure
everything looks like it
makes sense, like it worked.
The one thing you
might have, if it
is throwing you
issues and you're not
able to connect
this way, one way
I've been able to get
a workaround to this
is if you go to recreate the
database, which if you do,
make sure you delete
the previous one.
But if you go to recreate
the database, and let's
say you were going through
all these steps the same again
for each year still.
Let's leave that all the same.
The only difference is you could
try under Virtual Private Cloud,
create a new VPC.
If you do that, you can
leave that all there.
Still set public access to yes.
But you'll need to
create a new security
group because there
won't be any existing
in that virtual private cloud.
So if the way I showed
you before didn't work,
it should work if you
do it with creating
a new virtual private cloud.
But whatever works for you.
So yeah.
Just make it work
however you can.
So yeah.
Let me get back my notes now.
OK.
So we've got connected now.
And so now we should be able to
try and query from our database.
So let's see.
First off, we start with,
yes, we have demodb.
So you see, that was
what we created before,
the demodb that's
showing up there.
So let's upload some
new data to this,
so we actually have
a table to look at.
So I'm going to download
a file actually.
If you go to Canvas
and under Files,
there should be a
file called top10s.
It's just a Spotify or a
sample of a Spotify data
set of top 10 songs.
And so if you come and click
on demo here or on the--
there we go.
Under the demo database here,
if you right click on Tables,
you can do Table
Data Import Wizard,
and that's one way
you can upload data.
And so then you just
provide it the file path.
So I have this downloaded, or
I have it in my courses, 3,600.
And top10s next.
And then we'll do
Create New Table.
We'll just put it
under this, top10s.
If it already exists, you
can have that drop table
if exists and then do next.
And then under
here, you can just
leave these field
types as they are
or change them as
you feel necessary.
But again, this is
just a sample data set.
So we'll do next,
and we'll do next.
And it takes a little bit to do.
So this is a relatively
slow process.
Trying to see.
I don't want you guys
to have too many steps
because I think this might
be a little bit involved
for the next part.
But yeah, we'll do this.
And it takes a little
while because if you
think about what's
happening here,
I have a file that's
sitting on my computer.
I'm uploading it
through this wizard.
This wizard is having
to basically upload it
to the EC2 server and then
push it or that EC2 instance
wherever it is, and then push
it from that EC2 instance
into my RDS database instance.
So it's a little slow here.
You can always click
Show Logs if you
want to watch what steps
it's doing at that time.
But it's taking steps.
It's just, again,
it's very slow.
It's doing one data point
at a time effectively.
And this is a very,
very small data set.
If I pull it up here, we
can see it's wildly small.
So if we go top10s, and
let's look at Get Info.
So yeah.
It's just over 2
kilobytes of data.
So very, very small data set,
and it took that long to load.
So yeah, 28 rows.
It's not the biggest
one, but either way, this
is not the fastest way to do
it, but it is a way to do it.
And so once you
have that though,
you then should be able to
click the little refresh here,
and it should show
up under our tables.
So we have a little
drop down now, top10s.
And see all the details there.
Or like usually, you can just
select top down or select
everything from demodb.
And now again, you have
everything at your fingertips
from SQL as before, right?
For specifically MySQL.
So if you want to look
up any commands again,
they'll need to be
specifically MySQL commands.
But that is really the
process to get connected.
So select, I don't
know if I just
want to select maybe title from
this, where, I don't know, year.
I think you do it this way.
I have learned most of MySQL
in Microsoft SQL Server,
so I apologize if
things don't work
as well when I run them here.
That worked.
Perfect.
So select the top 10 songs,
the titles of the top 10 songs
from the year 2010.
So I think I'll leave it
at that because there's
going to be some
legwork, and you guys are
going to go through menus.
And I fear that there's
going to be some issues.
So why don't you try this first?
I'll put up an
assignment actually,
just to have you
upload this data set,
make sure you can get this
step done because the next step
after this is a
bit more involved.
But it'll give us a bit
faster of a way to do this.
So I'll leave it at that.
Come to me at the office
hours with questions.
Work through it.
Start playing around with it.
Look at the
assignment, run that,
and then we'll continue on.
So catch you next time.
Bye.
Actually, before you
go, I forgot to show you
how to delete your database.
It's a little obvious
of a step, but I want
to make sure it's very clear.
So first, I'm just going
to close out of this, out
of my MySQL Workbench.
Make sure to close
that out completely.
That way, there's no active
connection going to it.
And then from this
RDS page, there
should be DB instances
or database instances.
You can click this little radio
button there and click Delete.
Now again, I don't want to
create a final snapshot.
And this could actually
be a useful feature
if you were deleting this
to maybe do something
later on with it,
you might actually
want to delete
the final snapshot
or create a final snapshot.
But right now, we don't.
We're not going
to use this again.
So we're going to delete
that or not do that.
And then also, we're
going to uncheck retain
automated backups, right?
If there are any automated
backups that happen,
I don't need to
keep them anymore.
I can wipe those as
well unless I want to.
And then I'm going to
do, I acknowledge that
upon instant deletion, all
this stuff is getting dropped.
Then I'm going to type, delete
me, and we're good to go.
So again, just
please do that step.
It'll take a little
bit to shut down,
but I would like if
you guys make sure,
and also make sure you shut
down only your instance.
Don't touch anybody
else's instances.
I know right now, the way
this is set up, you could.
Please don't.
But yeah.
So just make sure you do
that before you disconnect,
and then we'll be good to go.
So once again, I'll see
you again from here.
And next time, we'll talk about
how to go a little bit more
deeper into this and
maybe leverage Python
to deploy or push our
data sets a bit faster.
OK, bye.